[Music]
hey you guys
i'm jenny this is tomes of terror this
is my horror book review show
so today we are going to be talking
about this book right here
the cabin at the end of the world by
paul
tremblay now those of you who have been
watching
uh my book review videos will note that
that one was not
on my 2021 tbr because i just kept
seeing it recommended everywhere so i
just decided on a whim that i was going
to pick it up
now this is actually not the first paul
tremblay novel that i have read
about a year year and a half ago i read
a head full of ghosts
which i liked very very much um also on
a lot of people's recommendation
um actually for this show probably
before the year is out i will probably
reread it and do a review on that one as
well
but this was a you know cabin at the end
of the world was
the second one that came up the most and
i really wanted to
read it and it's not very long it's
under 300 pages so i thought what the
hell
so i went ahead and ordered it now this
book i'm going to say right here and you
know i say this on most of them because
some
books i kind of spoil them some of them
not so much
this one i feel like i'm gonna have to
spoil it because it's really really hard
to talk about this book if you
can't spoil it that said uh
this is one of those books that
i think your experience reading it will
be a lot better
if you have no idea what's going on or
you know what's happening or what kind
of book it is
it is even um because that's kind of how
i approached it because the thing about
it is that
the description of this book that's on
the back and that's on goodreads and
stuff
very very vague and they do that on
purpose they don't really tell you what
kind of book this is what kind of novel
it is it's a horror novel obviously
but they just kind of give you the
barest minimum setup
which is literally maybe like the first
20 pages of the book you don't have any
idea like which way this thing is going
so if you want to read this book i would
recommend
not watching this video because i'm
going to spoil it because there's just
no
other way around it you can't talk about
the book without spoiling it but if you
want to read it
definitely don't watch this video
because you need to come at it
not knowing what's going to happen
because i think that it's
much more tense that way
because i just came to it by having no
idea what it was about
and just the the tension just builds up
and builds up because you're like what
the [ __ ] is going on here you know what
i mean
now this book it's pretty much
it's set only over a couple of days like
two three days something like that and
it's set all in one location
it is essentially uh
it's it's kind of like a home invasion
type story
but not exactly you know what i mean
like
with a twist so like i said from here on
out i'm going to talk about what this
book is out is about
so if you don't want to know anything
about it which i would recommend
then turn off the video go read the book
like i said it's under 300 pages it only
took me
probably like you know maybe four or
five hours to read it
and then come back and we can discuss it
because there's a lot to discuss
this book is pretty [ __ ] up it's it's
kind of [ __ ] up
i will say that now i read some of the
other reviews of it on goodreads
the reviews of this are like wildly all
over the place
um some of them were like you know five
stars this is the most messed up and
thing and it was awesome and everything
and then some people like one stars they
were so
disappointed um i will say too and like
i said spoilers
last warning if you don't like i'm going
to tell you right now if you don't like
ambiguous endings if you don't like
books that don't explain a lot of [ __ ]
that leave a lot of [ __ ] open-ended
then this will probably really piss you
off because this
big time uh leaves kind of the central
conceit
of the book which i'll get to in a bit
unanswered and unexplained i liked that
and i
liked because it kind of tied in with
the whole uh
you know kind of thematic thrust of the
book
but if you need [ __ ] tied up and you
need an ending
and um you want everything kind of
sorted out and explained then this is
not the book for you because that
this does not do that what's the setup
of this book did i mention that it came
out in 2018
it came out in 2018 so the setup of this
book
is there is a couple andrew and eric
and they have a daughter uh their
adopted daughter wen i believe she's
seven she's
and it's kind of coming up on her
birthday so she's gonna be eight years
old
and they have gone on vacation
to this very very remote cabin i think
it's up
i don't remember where it's at with like
oregon or washington state or something
something like that or near the canadian
border
it doesn't really matter so it's this
cabin
it's you know just in the middle of
nowhere there's no cell phone service
there's really no road to it you know
there's like a dirt road and it's really
long
and it's like four or five miles to the
main road nobody else around
super quiet so they wanted this cabin
specifically for this purpose because
they just wanted to get away from things
and unplug you know from the world for a
little while the cabin does have a tv
which is significant but other than that
nothing there's no
there's no cell phone service or
anything like that
so at the very beginning of the book
when the little girl
she's a very like precocious she's a
really like intelligent
child because some of the stuff is kind
of from her perspective
the perspective of this like shifts
around a lot you know throughout all the
characters
i didn't mind that because i kind of
liked you know the
the insight you know for each character
or whatever but um you know just keep in
mind that it
hops around um from character to
character uh there aren't that many
characters so it's not confusing or
anything like that
so when is basically you know her dads
are
kind of hanging out on the pool deck or
you know reading or whatever like laying
out the sun
and wind is kind of just playing in the
front yard she's catching grasshoppers
and she's
um you know putting them in a little jar
and naming them and you know saying what
you know this one's bigger than this one
and she's trying to figure out what they
eat she's studying them and everything
she's very like scientific
so while she's doing that this really
big burly dude kind of comes shambling
up the why not shambling
that that implies that it's like
nefarious
which okay i'll get to that a little bit
but so this
dude kind of approaches her and
obviously she's very wary because you
know
stranger danger but he seems
super nice even though he's like this
big gigantic
man but he seems very nice he says his
name is leonard
and he kind of sits down in the grass
with her and he's just kind of like
talking to her and they're catching
grasshoppers together
and she's like oh maybe this dude's all
right you know what i mean and i
this this opening scene even though it's
literally
just a little girl in a yard catching
grasshoppers and then this
dude wanders up this driveway because
like i said it's a long
driveway like it's a long way from the
main road and she you know wen didn't
hear a car she didn't see anybody else
and this dude just kind of wanders up
and starts talking to her
is like is really really good it's like
really tense because you have no idea
you know what this dude's motives are
you don't know what his end game is like
he seems nice
but you know a lot of [ __ ] serial
killers and kidnappers and [ __ ] like
that seemed nice too so it's just like
the whole time when they're having this
conversation about the grasshoppers
and he's like asking her about herself
and you know asking her about her dads
and all this other kind of stuff and
she's kind of
saying stuff about school and he's
really nice but it's also like really
sinister because you don't know
why he's there you don't know where he
came from so it's just this really good
so
i will say just in the first few pages i
was completely sucked in because i'm
like oh [ __ ] man what's going on here
so basically they talk for a little
while
and then he says something a little
strange and i'm kind of paraphrasing
because i don't want to like read
like you know word for word from the
book but he basically says something
like
i need to talk to your dads they're not
going to want
to let me in but they have to
nothing that's going to happen is your
fault he tells her that
and he says we need your help to save
the world
okay up to this point this this is
pretty much in the goodreads thing i
think like um
it even like on the back of the book
this is as far up as it goes
and like i said this is literally like
the first 15 20 pages of the book is
just the two of them talking and then
him saying this weird ass
thing so like i said if you just wanted
a little bit of a synopsis
that was it and uh from now on like i
said i'm just going to spoil the [ __ ]
out of it so
again i i know i said the last time was
final warning but this is the final
final final warning okay
just saying so at this point even though
leonard seems super nice and everything
like that
she's starting to get a little bit
nervous when he starts saying stuff like
that because it's a little weird
that's a little weird thing to say and
then she gets even more freaked out
when three more people come walking up
the driveway
and they're carrying what appear to be
like homemade weapons like they're kind
of like like a stick
like with garden tools like sticking out
of them and stuff
um i saw another reviewer saying like
like some purge type [ __ ]
you know it's just like somebody put
these weapons together like out of
garden tools and whatnot
and she notices too that all four of
them leonard and the other two
and the other three people it's another
man and two women
are all wearing a similar thing they all
have like jeans on and then they all
have button-up shirts but they're all
different colors
and at this point one's like yeah [ __ ]
this i'm out so she
runs inside the house now at this point
the four people they come up to the
cabin and start trying to convince
andrew and eric to let them in because
they have to talk to them about
something and they keep promising look
we don't want to hurt you
but we had to come here we were drawn
here
and you guys have to help us save the
world
or you know some really really bad [ __ ]
is gonna happen
andrew and eric not surprisingly as most
normal people
would uh are like yeah [ __ ] off
like what the hell are you even talking
about like you're coming to the cabin
trying to get in the cabin with weird
weapons
and spewing some nonsense about you have
to help us save the world i'm like
they're like no we're not having it
also they try to call the cops like i
said cell phones don't work but they do
have a landline
they try to call the cops but one of the
four
i think i believe it was sabrina she
cut the phone line which again is not
really endearing these people
to andrew and eric they're not doing a
very good job of conveying
whatever it is that they have to convey
because they just keep coming off
as threatening even though they keep
saying that they're not threatening
so like i said this whole time this
whole story takes place
in this cabin with these seven
characters andrew and eric and their
daughter wen
and the four people that you know that
came to the cabin
from who knows where so there's the only
seven characters in this whole entire
book
and like i said it takes place only over
two or three days i think
so at one point uh as i said not
surprisingly andrew and eric are just
not having us like these are just like
crazy people we don't know where they
came from it's like what are they doing
here they have weapons they cut our
phone line
um so obviously we're not gonna let them
in now at this point
the four are like look we don't really
wanna have to do this but we're gonna
have to force our way in because you
know you guys
really need to help us it's really
really important and all this other [ __ ]
so there's all this kind of like
back and forth and they finally they
bust into the cabin
and they tie up andrew and eric
at which point they don't tie up when
though and like i said they keep saying
i'm so sorry you know we
really didn't want to have to do it like
this and blah blah but basically
their story is that
they have had apocalyptic
visions of the end of the world
and whoever is giving them these visions
you're assuming it's god
has told them that andrew eric and when
have been chosen for whatever reason
one of them has to
sacrifice one of the other of them in
their family
otherwise the entire world will end
it is never explained why andrew and
eric and when were chosen
it was never they never explained that
they're like look we don't know we don't
know why we were chosen
uh we just all started having these same
visions
of the end of the world and we had a
vision of your cabin we had a vision of
your family
so we know that this is what's going to
happen and if you guys
don't choose one of the three in your
family to sacrifice
willingly then the entire world is going
to end and everyone is going to die
that's their story another aspect of
their story
is that because of course andrew and
eric don't believe them i mean who would
nobody would believe that right like
some just random [ __ ] people turn up
at your cabin and be like oh by the way
you know it was it
would be like man [ __ ] off [ __ ] off with
that so indeed they
they do not believe now what ends up
happening though is that as the days go
on
if like the longer they take to
sacrifice
uh one of their own the four
people that came to the cabin they have
to sacrifice one of their number
and it's almost kind of like they go
into a trance like they get taken over
by whatever it was that gave them the
visions and they have to kill
one of their number at which point
they're like okay well
now the disasters are going to happen so
leonard tells them
okay the first disaster is going to be
you know there's going to be this
massive
earthquake and then a massive tsunami
and so as soon as they he's kind of like
okay well you have to like choose to
make a sacrifice if you don't
then we're going to have the earthquakes
and the tsunamis so then he turns the tv
on like i said this is
significant that there is a tv in the
cabin so he turns the news on
and indeed there has been a huge
earthquake and then another earthquake
and then there's a tsunami
and it kills like a whole bunch of
people like along the western seaboard i
believe i'm
i can't remember what part of the
country was parts of california in
washington state or something like that
and it wipes out like a whole bunch of
people and he's like see
it's like if you don't the longer you go
without sacrificing one of your number
then this is just gonna keep getting
worse and worse and then once
all of us are dead then because like i
said if they don't
pick one then one of the four they go
into a trance and beat
one of their own to death which is
pretty
horrific then um then it's just going to
keep ramping up and then
once all four of us are dead um if you
guys don't sacrifice me
then the entire world is going to end
and everyone's going to die
now so this goes on and obviously like i
said andrew and eric don't really
believe them but there is enough
of an uncertainty there because
obviously they're just like okay we're
just gonna wait at
wait it out because these four people
are obviously crazy
and are just gonna kill each other off
so
you know let's just wait them out then
they'll all be dead and then we can get
the [ __ ] out of here
because they don't i mean the four
people they they [ __ ] up their car so
they couldn't leave
and uh they have a car but they didn't
save like they hid the keys and all this
other kind of [ __ ] and they can't call
for help because there's no
the landline's been cut so it goes on
like over the days where
you know like i said i think think it's
only two or three days where
they keep killing one of their own like
one of the four people
and uh then he'll turn on the tv and
he's like oh look
a whole bunch of planes fell out of the
sky that's you know the sky
falling or whatever and so it's really
interesting
that some [ __ ] that happened
and it's it's funny because the two um
the two dads andrew and eric i think
it's andrew
is real uh a rationalist he's like an
atheist and so he has an explanation for
every single thing he's like dude it's
like all you have to do is like turn on
the news at any time
like cable news at any time and there's
going to be some [ __ ] disaster on
there
he's like you know yeah it's earthquake
and tsunami that [ __ ] happens and it's
like then the next one was like a bird
flu and he's like that's been going on
for months and months it's like
you know and maybe they even knew about
it beforehand and so they
put that into their narrative whereas
eric the other one
he's kind of um a catholic he's not
super
uh you know fundamentalist about it or
anything like that but he is a believer
so he's almost kind of like believing
this [ __ ] you know what i mean he's like
but that all this
can't be a coincidence and all this
other kind of stuff so as it goes on
it's it's really interesting because
it's almost like there's no way to know
if you're wrong or not because if you
know if for some reason
like andrew eric and when they did
believe these people
and they're like okay well we'll
sacrifice one of our number and they do
it
then the world would just go on so you
don't know if the world
would have ended if they didn't do that
you know what i'm saying and as i said
in this book you do not find out they
they don't tell you so as the [ __ ] goes
on like i said the
the four people who spoiler alert i
guess
are supposed to represent the four
horsemen of the apocalypse that's why
they all have different colored shirts
on it's you know
you know it's kind of goes along with
you know the pale horse and
all the other kind of stuff so they're
all different like one has a white shirt
one has a
kind of pearl like off-white shirt one
has like a you know whatever whatever
the
the colors were that represented but
they're supposed to be the four horsemen
of the apocalypse
so basically three of them are
dead because obviously uh andrew and
eric
uh refuse to sacrifice them to anybody
so there's kind of all kind of tussling
and stuff like that and then
there's a really really horrible moment
andrew
i think it's is it eric or andrew i
can't believe but i i can't remember but
like one of them
actually is able to get out of his
restraints he runs out
to the suv that they drove there
and he is able to get his gun out
so he brings the gun back into the thing
it's like they you know have this big
tussle over it during the tussle
and this is really upsetting you guys
during the tussle
gwen gets shot in the face and killed
accidentally um while they're struggling
over the gun
now it's really really interesting how
they how this is put across in the story
because it's almost kind of like it's
it's a big deal and you see like a lot
of the aftermath
but it's really interesting that it's
not
they don't make this huge over dramatic
i mean it happens
just like that like in the blink of an
eye and then the reactions that they
have to it because
everyone's in shock and they're like
freaking out and it's it's very
very realistic so i will say that this
part
this was like super upsetting because
really
when and her two dads i mean the
characterization in this
is so so good that when it happens
you're just kind of like you just feel
like you've been [ __ ]
smacked in the mouth you know what i
mean because it's like this is little
girl and you thought something
you thought they were going to get away
or you thought something and then that
happens and it's just kind of like out
it's not out of the blue but it's it's
just like really it's like a punch in
the gut
particularly because you've spent so
much time with these characters and
you've really like started to like them
so wen gets killed but because she was
killed accidentally
the rules say that it has to be a
willing
sacrifice no one meant to sacrifice her
it just happened accidentally when they
were struggling over the gun
so her death doesn't count
which means that maybe
if what all the stuff that the four
horsemen are saying is true
then andrew and eric one of them will
have to kill
the other one willingly or one will have
to kill himself willingly
now once when is dead and they're pre
and then
all of the other um you know the four
horsemen are dead
except for one and then finally she
is just kind of like okay well i don't
like this i don't like the way this is
going
you know if if this is god that gave me
these
visions and drew me here and you know is
going to end the world because
i don't like it that's [ __ ] up and so
she says
that she's going to lead andrew and eric
uh
to where they hid the keys to their
vehicle and it's like you guys you know
i don't know what's going to happen
i don't know if the world's going to end
so you guys just just try to go just get
out of here
so that's pretty much where it ends when
she takes them she um
she shows them the keys then she kills
herself so andrew and eric are left
with their dead daughter and they're
kind of discussing
well you know it's like i could kill you
and that i could kill myself or it's
like you know the ones that like well i
could kill myself and then they have
this whole thing about it
but then finally they decide you know
what we're just
we're just gonna go we're just gonna see
what happens
so the fact that they didn't sacrifice
themselves and now
all of the um four horsemen are dead you
don't ever find out
whether the world ended or not or
whether those people were
completely full of [ __ ] and were just
four crazy people who happened to
meet on a random message board and which
is how they
got together because you know they got
on a message board they were like hey
i'm having these weird apocalyptic
visions anybody else and then
you know and then that happens and they
all got kind of drawn to certain areas
so i really really like this the whole
like ambiguity
about you know is the world gonna end
were they telling the truth
um you know or were they just just
delusional because
you could see it either way like there
were yes there was a lot of coincidences
yes it was this on the other
but there were still there was still
plausible deniability there was still
reasonable explanations for a lot of the
[ __ ] that happened so it's completely
possible
that these people were just nuts and
happened to
you know meet in a message board and
they were kind of like feeding into each
other's delusions
and then they went to find these random
people and that the world isn't going to
end at all
and andrew and eric might be totally
fine um
obviously other than their daughter
being dead
which is horrible or it could be that
they just said okay we're just gonna go
on and see what happens
and it could be that the four horsemen
were correct and the world is entirely
gonna end
so i like i kind of like that he left it
up to you
i guess to decide what you think is
going to happen i don't really know what
i thought was going to happen because i
think the whole time i was reading it
i was sitting there i was kind of more
on andrew's side like the skeptic dude
i'm like i
if this happened to me i would just
think these people were nuts
and uh there's no way i would do it
because it was
there was there was just there was a
reasonable explanation for everything
it's like some of the [ __ ] that happened
was weird
but it's nothing you couldn't explain
away rationally so i really like that he
kind of like left that ambiguity
so i'm kind of more of the mind that the
world
probably wasn't gonna end but it could
go either way
so you say yeah so it's one of those
kind of books that
it'll just kind of make you think about
that kind of
like the end of the world like what
would happen if you were in this
situation and all this other kind of
crap
so yeah it was really like food for
thought really well written the
characterization like i said was really
really good
uh the tension was really great like
just kind of ramped up and ramped up i
mean i read it really quick
because i just you know i wanted to see
what happens like where the hell is this
going where are they going with this
you know then when gwen got killed it
was like this big [ __ ] slap in the
face and i was like holy [ __ ] i can't
believe you did that
i don't know if i'd call it a fun read
necessarily because it's kind of
[ __ ] up and kind of disturbing pretty
gory too like when the four horsemen
people start killing each other off
uh they do it like in a really horrible
like bludgeoning kind of way with their
weird tools or whatever so it's like
there's a lot of gore in it a lot of
[ __ ] up [ __ ] in it i don't know i
i just found it like really really
compelling i thought it was really
really good even though it went
even though it was like nothing like i
was imagining you know what i mean it
was kind of like home invasion meets
revelation you know the book of
revelation it was kind of that type of
thing
which is weird but i was i was into it i
was into it
so uh so yeah but basically as i said
this is really good and
i hear a lot about paul tremblay and
i've read one of his other books as i
said head full of ghosts which is also
very very good
i think i liked head full of ghosts
slightly better than this one but i
don't know it's
it's kind of hard because they're
they're really close and also
the stories um are very very different
so it's kind of hard to
compare them but if you've read some of
his other stuff
um you know and you haven't read this
one yet i definitely would recommend
this one
um as i said it's different than head
full of ghosts and i think all of his
stuff
is kind of you know different from one
another he doesn't really
he has a style but not you know every
book isn't the same thing or in the same
style like he likes to do different
things
so uh so definitely check it out i found
it really compelling like i said now
some people on goodreads really did not
like it and found it
really disappointing um particularly
because of the ambiguity of how it ended
it's like it you know wasn't tied up
there were some other things that were
left um unexplained
like at one point one of the uh one of
the men had been
the uh had been the victim of a hate
crime
like several years earlier and he
thought that one of the dudes that came
there
who was going by the name of redmond was
actually the dude that had
uh assaulted him many years ago
um and they never and he's like certain
of it so he's like that's how i know
that these people are full of [ __ ]
because i know who that dude is
and he's lying to you about what his
name is because his name isn't redmond
so but they never do tell you you know
that the book does not tell you like
whether that dude was actually the dude
that assaulted him or whether
or whether he was just seeing it that
way because he was looking for something
to grasp onto like why
you know a reason that he could say that
these people were full of [ __ ]
um so it's just really really intriguing
it had all these like
questions that were left unanswered but
left unanswered
for a purpose if that makes any sense
but yeah definitely definitely a good
one
um i would recommend this like i said
it's kind of messed up uh you know
kids getting shot in the face so it's a
little messed up
but uh but yeah if you're into that kind
of stuff if you've read any of his other
books and haven't read that one
then i definitely recommend this one so
check it out
and i will see you on the next one bye